what music right like words couldn't use
that come from what it used to come from
it comes from people that are growing up
being influenced by things but it's
naive ATAG now you can tell being native
like like that's what happened here at
vaynermedia I didn't know anything about
the agency world and that's why we're
drawing one of the fastest agencies
because I'm asking dumb questions but
those dumb questions are grounded in
business and so you know when you know
what the rules are you play within them
I mean this has been long figured out
right there's science and psychology
that wraps around like you know listen I
wasn't a great student right and I'm not
well-read and I'm gonna tell you right
now that's my advantage like there's a
lot of things I don't know I say things
that people think they're brilliant
statements they've been said before they
just were set in different ways and if I
actually knew how they said that I would
lose that quote but I don't suck and I
think that it's a funny thing to think
about it think about that a lot then I
get a lot of credit for a lot of things
that are actually grounded in weaknesses
not strikes